Mark pedals his bike
70 times in a minute.
Which of these are
reasonable estimates
about Mark's peddling?
Mark all that applies.
So let's just think
about this a little bit.
70 times in a minute.
So there are 60
seconds in a minute.
So if he's doing 70
times in a minute,
if he was doing 60
then he would be
peddling once per second.
Since he's doing 70
times in a minute,
he's doing a little bit
more than once per second.
So maybe that'll help
us right over here.
So here it says Mark
peddles his bike what?
4,000 times every second.
Well, that's nuts.
If he peddled his bike
4,000 times every second,
you'd have a way huger
number right over here.
You'd have 4,000
times per second times
60 seconds per minute.
You would have a huge
number right over here.
If it's 70 times in
a minute, we just
reasoned that he
peddles a little
over one time in a second.
So this is definitely not right.
Mark pedals his bike
about once every hour.
Well, an hour is 60 minutes.
So if he does 70
times in a minute,
he's going to do 60
times 70 in an hour.
So this is also crazy, that
he only does once in an hour.
This is unbelievably slow.
Mark pedals his bike
about once every second.
Well, we've already
reasoned that there's
60 seconds in a minute, and
he does 70 times in a minute.
So he does a little over--
if you divide 70 by 60,
so you could divide
70 by 60, and you're
going to get a number
that's a little bit over 1
time per second.
So this is right.
We're estimating.
We don't get exact numbers.
It's about once every second.
So that seems legitimate.
Mark pedals his bike about
4,000 times every hour.
So let's think about that.
If he pedals 70
times in a minute,
and then there are 60
minutes in an hour,
this is going to be
equal to 70 times 60.
Well, we can multiply
the 7 times the 6,
and we get 7 times 6 is 42.
And we have two zeroes here.
So we have exactly
4,200 times every hour.
So as an estimate,
this is pretty close.
So I would go with that as well.